genius brain farts this podcast is
brought to you by fume have you ever
tried to break a bad habit but you had
so much trouble well guess what let's
talk about our sponsor fume stopping is
something we all put off because it's
hard but try switching to fume it's easy
enjoyable and even fun fume has served
over 150,000 customers and has thousands
of success stories and there's no reason
that can't be you join fume and
accelerating Humanity's breakup from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to tri.com and
use code genius to save 10% off when you
get the journey pack today that's try
f.com and use code genius to save the
additional 10% off your order today this
podcast is brought to you by
nordvpn if you are online and you're
telling me right now that all you do is
watch videos so you don't need a VPN you
are freaking dumb you are just online
naked as hell and everybody's watching
everything that you do what you should
do is get
nordvpn nordvpn deal amazing users can
get get a huge discount with the
purchase of a 2-year plan plus 4 months
free and let me tell you something your
online security is worth all that so
exclusive grab the nordvpn deal today
and go to
nordvpn.com geniusbrain and get extra
subscription time try it risk-free now
with a 30-day money back guarantee
thanks to nordvpn for sponsoring our
show genius brain listeners before we
start this podcast thank you to our
sponsor over at haries my friends no
matter why you shave Harry's has you
covered for the best shave of your life
at a price you'll love listen I've
already told you I've had Harry's
products before they even started
sponsoring this podcast so it was a
no-brainer I love them because guess
what the value that you get for the
price you pay is unmatched specifically
for a highquality Razor get your best
shave ever with Harry's razors and
skincare products get a $13 star for
just $3 at harry's.com genius that's
harry's.com genius for a $3 starter set
today I'm on only fans the world what
are you doing the world went to [__]
when [__] Rachel doas all opened up
on only fans yes oh my God yeah hey I'm
not going to lie rdit in that fit now
she got some nice titties my question is
is her in five 4 3 two one Aloha you
stupid [__] I have my what I have my
Hawaii outfit because I know it's going
to get cold and guess what I'm wearing
this [__] M we got a very special guest
here we have Emanuel from dorm tment
what's up everybody thanks for having me
David how long have I [__] known you
now God damn it's been at least 10 years
10 plus years dude 2013 yeah man long
[__] time man back when YouTube was a
different space yeah man you weren't
dressing like a GTA character as I said
earlier I'm I'm bringing back a joke I
said in front of I'm doing cocaine every
[__] night bring back my joke
strippers what you been up to man I've
been good man working man trying to
figure out you know how this whole
YouTube thing is going down man it's
[__] different the space it's
different it's it's very different a lot
of scammers in this game it seems like
that's what's popular I was talking
about this too with a few of my friends
and you know when we we started doing
YouTube and social media back in the day
everybody's stuff was so different it
was you know like people if people were
doing comedy everybody's comedy was
different and now you just see a carbon
copy of everybody [__] Jus Christ man yo
me and Tim were talking about this where
we have this pet peeve where you'll see
trend on Tik Tok or Instagram right and
then everybody does it but they do the
exact same job same thing right like why
don't you add your own [__] to it I
think it's cuz they get used to doing
like
dances you know you do a dance on Tik
Tok everybody does the same dance
there's no necessarily creativity they
might add one leg up rather than down
but at the same time they're just
copying that I feel like that became the
trend just just do what the other people
are doing yeah you know what I mean and
and that's how it kind of became with
the comedy of yeah like I saw like a lot
of these jokes where like for example
there was this a joke that was going
around where uh people were getting
skeletons and they were doing like
Chiropractic back cracks but it was the
same [__] wait I just saw this somebody
else do this that's so Random then I'm
like who's the originator of this joke
like who was the first one and yeah how
does that person get that credit they
don't they just everybody just steals it
and then they just move on with it and
then nobody cares cuz I know like back
in the day like stealing people's
material was a big thing like you can't
like why the [__] would you do that well
who is Tik Tock back by Chinese of
people come on who steals come on you
know steal everything what type of IP
who why wouldn't we learn to steal each
other's stuff from China come on did you
see that interview with the guy I think
the main I think they're Taiwanese I'm
not sure but the the guy was basically
speaking to some big crowd important
people anyways and they were asking him
well how do you feel about Tik Tok like
infiltrating the the minds of like young
young consumers and they go well in
China kids aren't allowed on adult Tik
Tok like what are you talking about like
I've heard that we regulate our kids
stuff they're just kind of Silent
they're like they're only allowed to
have it for like two hours be on it two
or three hours no more yeah adult
content is not allowed until they hit 18
they're like what are you guys
doing uh we just want to destroy your
kid yeah exactly which is so smart and I
think for like I'm not all about like
censorship or anything else like that
but definitely for like our younger
generation I do feel like we should
protect what they watch cuz it's like
too much exposure like we didn't have
this all this [__] grown up no and I you
know when when pandemic happened one of
the things that I saw that that Tri me
out was watching kids play outside there
was [__] tons of kids playing outside
and I hadn't seen that [__] in years let
me ask you were you dressed like this
while watching kids play 100% my dick
was
out love of
God I was just watching the kids like
this hey kid I enjoy you guys having a
good time hey Mom hey Dad want to sit on
my lap I'll give you a treat I just tip
my hat to them hello
children are you a fan of Michael
Jackson he's my hero we get these weird
voices I we were talking about on the
podcast a while back too where I you
know they started doing all this
documentaries on Michael Jackson and
then I saw this one video that made me
believe that Michael didn't do it was
him talking about titties and I was like
there's no I saw I love that video that
is one of my favorite videos of Michael
Jackson of all look at them
fishies
on I've never seen that that man turned
into such a southern black man in my
life like look at him you
see like what the [__] he still got it
he still got it okay but uh yeah you
know that I could see how that could put
a a damper on pedophile rumors I guess
you know for you guys right you guys
were doing um so many sketches and I'm
like you know I wonder for you guys when
you guys decided to make that switch to
stop doing sketches because we all
stopped doing sketches yeah I think for
us it was a burnout I I'll say for me it
was definitely a burnout you know I I
reached that point where I was
like you know cuz we we we you know we
came into the game with the weekly thing
we wanted to make as much of a of of
YouTube into a show as possible and so
we were like every Sunday at 7 that's
when you're watching out for a d
entertainment skit and it just got to
the point you know after so many years
we've moved we started doing things in
the industry and a lot of times that can
damper on your initial you know what
you're doing you know you start off with
doing skits and stuff but then they they
ask you hey what movie ideas what TV
shows what all this and now you're
waiting on industry stuff while trying
to get this done and it kind of becomes
kind of
uh
tough you know did you did you feel that
when you guys started switching over
into more traditional like Hollywood
type of stuff did it put like a bad
taste in your mouth cuz it did for me
yeah like the hardest part for me was
you know when we started going into
YouTube it was such a free space right
there's no red tape if we wanted to
create something we just created and
there was nobody else that could tell us
otherwise right when when I started
going into this and I had to shake hands
I had to smile a little more I had to do
all these meetings where it didn't
turned out to be anything at all it
started like eating away at me I'm like
who the [__] are you people to tell me
what I can and can't do no I I
immediately see why suicide rate in
Hollywood's High dude it's just this is
this is a terrible place a part of me is
excited right now because of the
destruction that's going on and I'm
sorry to you actors and good people out
there but at the end of the day a part
of me wants to see Disney explode part
of me wants to see some of these
corporations just shut the [__] up okay
because the way they've run business
where we come from such an innocent
place to be honest with you doing skits
and just having get Gathering your
friends and just doing something
creative on YouTube was always just like
a fun passionate thing to do we're just
having fun we're having a good time we
found out a way to make some money off
of it we can prosper a little bit but
it's like once you enter this industry
stuff and they try to control you or you
see the games that people play and all
this dumb [__] it's not it's it's not
that it's just not fun it becomes
tiresome it feels like it draining you
of like you know and well how many
[__] mass and faces do we have to put
on Jesus Christ man and like I think
that the the interesting thing
was I have a I'm not sure if people
knows I I have I have a problem of you
know holding back to things I want to
say so like I love that the same page so
so we go to these meetings and then you
know I see a lot of people kind of
laughing at everything and I'm like
there was nothing funny said why the the
[__] are so many people laughing right
now right right you know and when I went
to this one mixer it was for like this
ABC event and I was there and a lot of
these actors don't know who's an
executive and who's important or who's
not so they're just literally going up
to [__] and then sucking the [__]
out of it to every person and they don't
cuz they don't know they just want to
make sure that they have a job and so
you know for me I show up at this mixer
event like this like flipflop shirts and
a t-shirt cuz I don't know what this
[__] is I I was just told to come and
I'm going to show up as comfortable as I
be so I showed up and there was this one
guy still don't know who this guy's name
was but he was just laughing at
everything that I was saying and I was
looking at him and I was like wait I
don't think he understands like I'm not
an a casting director or an executive
right so you could I could tell he was
like kissing my ass and then in the
middle of the conversation when I
realized that put my hand on the
shoulder I was like I'm not a casting
director like you ain't got to do all
this you know got to me and the guy was
like oh I do I was like no you didn't do
you you you do you thought I was
somebody special and I'm not you know
I'm just here cuz I was invited you know
getting the opportunity to direct
something or or when when you start
getting this little bit of power of
being able to create on your own and and
people want you and all this stuff it's
you know for most people I mean maybe
for a lot of people they like it and
from the outside looking in you know
fans of us and stuff they're often like
you know wow that's that's really cool
but it's kind of annoying oh dude it's
crazy annoying it's just really annoying
it's like I don't want you kissing my
ass just be human yeah just if if we
have a job do the [__] job I don't
need you to like suck up to me because I
know this isn't you you wouldn't do this
if I was just a regular yeah just a
regular person so just be you and do
your job or whatever and let's get it
done and maybe we could be cool but the
the kiss ass thing doesn't work for me I
don't like the fakery of and like actors
too they're always put into this weird
place because you know they they have
their set opinions right but they won't
say it because they're always scared
that they're going to lose a job so what
they'll do is they'll take the [__]
they'll pretend like they like everybody
and then they'll talk [__] about
somebody's back they'll come back and it
just becomes this whole just terrible
toxic type of thing that you're in and I
just remember going to these meetings
going to these events and I just hated
everybody I'm like I I have not met a
single person here that I like if I have
a conversation with you I still don't
know who you are right and then you know
if I talk to them outside of this then
they're a lot more relaxed but it's just
like how often do you have to do this
like cuz if I have to do this every day
I can't do this for a [__] living and
I think like so after I did the film I I
tried doing acting and you know till
this day I I'll still audition but it's
a weird space to be in where when we
were doing stuff we did it because we
liked it not because we needed it right
and so for this for a lot of actors
they're literally vying for a paycheck
and so they'll take and do absolutely
anything yeah and so they're kissing ass
they're doing all this stuff just so
they could pay their [__] bills and
for me I don't have that I'm like listen
like I've myself outside of this this is
a bonus like I've done everything that I
wanted to but let me see if I could do
this as well if it's like when I when I
dropped my
agent you know one of the bigger
conversations that we had before I
decided that I didn't want to be with
them was he was like sending me these
auditions right and it was for I'm not
saying that I'm above these roles right
but I have a certain amount of time
right I'm still doing my own thing and
so it would be like oh I want you to go
in for this audition for this casting
director it's like I just had lunch with
that casting director I don't need to
meet them right I am and they go okay
cool but it's it's for like a small it's
like a oneliner and I'm like I don't
want to do this audition and he goes why
not and I'm like because I don't need it
yeah you know and it's and it's hard to
tell them I don't need this like give me
something that I can care about and so
you know when I started getting call
backs and stuff they get super excited
but in that initial conversation they're
just like oh this guy's not going to
make it it's like well you don't know
what I can or can't do you know and so
after I dropped them I booked the
Netflix thing and then lo and behold
they messed me congratulations like no
no no no no we're not doing this whole
rul [__] we had this whole long
extensive conversation you told me that
you essentially were saying that I
wasn't going to make it and then I
booked this big thing and then you
messag me back it's like we're done here
and I I dislike that because the
Hollywood game man it's a Hollywood
Shuffle and like the conversations that
they kind of have with you is and I'm
pretty sure they have to do this with
their job but they're trying to make it
seem like oh we're buddies like we're
not buddies like you have a like a
contractual obligation to make sure I
book stuff so you get paid right so s me
things that I'll that I can kill it at
right don't let me tell you this one
audition dog I got this audition before
it was like a a version of they were
trying to reboot something like a
version of Teen Wolf MH okay and the
role this is before the late latest one
or something that came yeah this is this
is this was some other spin-off of the
new version of Teen Wolf okay okay okay
okay and the role was for a young 20s
handsome buff werewolf I was 300 lb at
the time I get this audition I look at
the script I look at the descriptors I'm
like who the [__] is this for like what
is it I call my agent I'm like hey why
why would I audition for this and he
goes well I just want you to go in front
of this casting director I'm like do you
have any the lines are so as I was do
reading the lines I was trying not to
laugh cuz at this point when I was like
what 29 yeah and it was for like a 21y
old that is it literally says physically
fit right I'm 300 lb I
spilling out my shirt and in fact I
gained so much weight I didn't have a
shirt that fit me at the time so my
shirt looked like a wet suit oh my God I
got the [__] nipples poking out I got
six rolls coming out come on man that
sounds sexy to me ladies and gentlemen
come on man and you can't say that wolf
right here if there was a full moon I
would turn into a
bulldog there's no breathing issues and
all hi everybody I'm a
werewolf [__] gay too the hell
what the [__] is going on dog I was so
mad but I kept running into these like
situations and you know some of my actor
friends didn't understand they go dude I
would kill to be in your position to get
you know these auditions and I'm like
that's the difference it's like I'm not
killing for these roles do you feel
you're more Creator would you consider
yourself or like what what CU I feel
like there has there's a difference
between those who want to act and be in
stuff and be picked up and those who
want to just like I just want to create
my thing I think that's what it is too
right I don't need Spotlight yeah yeah
yeah if I could let's say if I wrote
something and somebody else did it or
even if I wrote something somebody else
took the crate but I got a fat Paycheck
Take it I don't give a [__] cuz it's not
about me right I got my satisfaction
because I got to create something but
you're not going to take it for free if
if somebody came up to you right I wrote
the script somebody fell in love with it
they go I want my name on I'll take your
name off it here's 5 mil take it I don't
give a [__] don't give a [__] I'll write
something else again that's the one
greatest thing that I learned in
Hollywood is that what do they say don't
don't be don't uh don't be attached to
the baby yeah you know what I'm saying
like throw it out with the bath
water with the bath I think that's how
the phrase goes yeah they kill a lot of
babies in Hollywood apparently yeah so
um so I think yeah don't being so
attached to that script or that that one
project and if it goes It goes if it
goes without you and you're able to make
whatever just just keep it moving yeah
and I I think sometimes for young
creators too like you guys you guys
think every single one of your ideas are
so precious that you just kind of sit on
these ideas nothing is precious and if
you only have one good idea then this
might not be for you exactly right
exactly and I think for me I kept on
sitting on ideas for so long I just
wouldn't do anything and like piss or
get off the pot and then what you'll
find is that you had this great idea
somebody else is going to think of
something very similar they'll do it and
you'll be like oh I missed my right
exactly and it happens it happened to me
a lot it happens to a lot of young
people so I I like one of my uh one of
my friends hit me up because one of his
friends wants to get into clothing right
and I I have the brand secret society
nice and sometimes with these kids like
they don't they're not asking you for
advice they're asking you to reaffirm
what they already believe and like this
kid kind of irritated me because he was
asking how to get in the clothing and
I'm like I don't know to be honest with
you like well what do you what do you
think success is like do you think I'm a
very successful person in clothing he
goes yeah I saw your stuff I was like
well you and everybody mom has a [__]
clothing brand dude pretty much you know
there's space for everybody but
basically I was telling him this is like
if you want to get into clothing you
better be ready to leave everything
because it fashion moves fast and if you
don't have it you don't have it and
sometimes people who don't have it have
better connections M so if you're
willing to die for this then do it
because out of all the things that I've
done clothing has been the most
difficult and if I could redo it I
probably wouldn't do it again has it
been Pro as prosperous if no profits are
there you know it's it's not my my issue
is this right it's
like I I always want to create because
like I said I'm a Creator right the
vision is so important to me right there
are definitely things that we could do
to make a bigger paycheck but then at
the end of the day when I leave and I
pass I want to be very happy with the
things that I do CU I didn't have to
create this clothing brand right we
didn't have to create secret society but
for me it was like oh this is a a gap
that's missing in this space I want to
make sure that my goal is to be a hous
name brand where everybody has it in
their closet yeah and if I can't do that
then there's no point to this then it's
just a paycheck because if we wanted to
just make a paycheck we could just work
a [__] 9 to5 you godamn right right
right you know what I'm saying so why
not just do that we we go into work
obviously not everything's guaranteed
but at least I know what I'm doing and I
can walk away with a paycheck and then
if this job doesn't work out I'll apply
to another one yeah I bare minimum I
rather go off you know if if I'm going
to fail I'll fail on my own terms rather
than whatever other people says you know
an employer or whatever um but I do like
that like do you find with fashion
though has that always been a big
passion of yours well for me like listen
I never wear clothes but I love clothes
the reason why is because I'm always
doing [__] like I'm always like every
morning I walk five miles right and then
I kickbox and I box there's no [__]
way in between this that I'm going to
wear something that I enjoy like I'm
sweating hilar all the time so years ago
I just said you know what [__] it you I
mean we'll put what I like into clothing
here for me I'm a dress like a drug
dealer just going to leave it at that
yeah that's the guy that owns the come
ony no that's cool as hell do you do you
have to keep up is it a matter of
keeping up with Trends or trying to set
a trend it's a little bit of both right
so for us we are our branding was like
so so my partners have been into
clothing for a long time right but they
don't understand branding right so one
of the biggest issues that they had when
they first started was they were trying
to be too cool for school right so if I
my my thing is that I always tell people
when you start a brand you need to tell
me what your brand is within one
sentence if you can't do it [__] off and
go back to the drawing board cuz
nobody's going to sit here and listen to
a [__] 10-minute diet tribe about why
you think you're cool tell me what you
are I'm cool cuz when I grew up exactly
this isn't a Yelp Elite review right
nobody gives a [__] about the sandwich
that you ate in the morning and then
about your husband who didn't [__] you
nobody cares so like with one of my
partners his biggest issue was like I
would ask him so what is secret society
and he goes well okay be I'm like no no
no no I already don't [__] care it's
just like a movie Pitch right what is it
in one we are high quality fashion
Basics that's it right people need to
know that right and we're trying to fill
in this space that other people don't
have and I think for me you know when I
buy garments and clothing it's like I
like value like I don't want to wear
something and then have it die out fast
fashion became huge right because it
became for the everyday person who
wanted clothes but everybody [__]
knows when you get stuff from Sheen you
get stuff from H&M what the [__] happens
when you was it once it falls apart it's
wrecked you could either spend 25 bucks
on this one item or you could spend
maybe even double even but you keep it
for the rest of your life and fashion
Basics never die they stay around
forever so that's why I like fashion
Basics genius brain listeners this
podcast is brought to you by fume cold
turkey may be great on sandwiches but
there's a better way to break your bad
habits and we're not talking about some
weird mind voodoo from your crazy
neighbor we're talking about our sponsor
fume and they look at the problem in a
different way not everything in a bad
habit is wrong so instead of drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit tastes great
super super fun to fidget with and guess
what if you have a oral fixation this is
better my friends because when you take
a little puff of like that herbal tea
fruity flavor that I did man super super
good stopping is something we all put
off because it's hard but switching to
fume is easy enjoyable and even fun fume
has served over 150,000 customer and has
thousands of success stories and there's
no reason that can't be you join fume
and accelerating Humanity's breakup from
destructive bad habits by picking up the
journey pack today headit to tri.com and
use code genius to 10% off when you get
the journey pack today that's TR
f.com and use code genius to save an
additional 10% off your order today so
this is the this is where we wanted to
carve out our space you know beautiful
beautiful yeah I love that man you you
you dabble in different areas and you're
and you're passionate about each one you
know what I'm saying because there are a
lot a lot of people that jump into all
these area I find a lot of artist I was
talking with the guys the other day
about rappers today like a lot of
rappers like especially the ones of our
age generation like the the Drake The
Big Sean the you know the J Cole's all
these guys they do so many different
things that I don't know if there's a
lot of times is there an elite artist of
just this of hip-hop of just this rap
anymore like are there are can you still
just be an artist at this or do you have
to diversify into all these things
because it makes it kind of makes it
hard to point out who's great yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know what I'm saying who's
great when this not your complete Focus
Michael Jordan His complete Focus was
that uh Mike Tyson his complete Focus
was that now these are Athletics you
know I know it's not exactly what we do
and other artists doing [__] but it it
just kind of I have that problem of do I
how how focused do you be on something
yeah how much can you diversify and
still be great at it I I'll say this
right so got like diagnosed with like
ADHD like six seven months ago which I
already knew I had it but you know I
just got the test and then I was like in
denial the whole time like I was talking
to the doctor they like you might have
adhc I was like listen here [__] you
don't know [__] even though even though
I paid her I set up this whole thing you
know but it's like okay you know I'm in
denial you know for a lot of creatives
what we're finding out too is like ADHD
is very common for creatives we are all
we we require a lot of high stimulation
you know Trad traditionally in a
traditional Workforce sense it's
probably the worst you have to sit down
sit still get your work done and do it
for people who are creative that's very
very difficult and what happens for
people with like ADHD we need High
stimulations to stay focused so for most
people and this was explained to me by
the doctors like for most people when
they do like remedial task whether it's
finishing a task a job or whatever they
get a a I don't know if this is the
right term but a a basic a baseline
endorphin hit for completing a task and
doing stuff for someone who has like
ADHD MH or ad or whatever that is you
try to do it you get a zero endorphin
hit and so it you just cannot [__]
Focus so things like riddlin and all
these other things they basically allow
you to focus because it gives you that
little [__] that everybody else has I
would never suggest somebody who wants
to be successful in the space to do the
things the way that I do it it is
[__] chaos sit down focus on one task
and become a master at your craft okay
okay so you you would actually suggest
the opposite
yeah if you don't have if you don't have
my itchy ass syndrome or I'm just [__]
it you know what I mean then I wouldn't
suggest you do what I do because it's
also very like anxiety inducing right
but for me what's anxiety inducing for
most people for me it's just the chaos
that I enjoy but you know the other good
part about me is that I'm always
somebody who likes to be a man of my
word so if I say I'm going to complete
it I'm going to complete it you know
with this clothing brand you know
[__] pandemic almost wrecked us right
we were bleeding we didn't make anything
for almost three years and then you know
developing the relationship with the
people that we sold the clothing to and
then also the fan base they revived it
back our first year back and [__]
took all us all back out of the negative
we were back in the positive [__]
fantastic so you know I think for me
what I what I kind of done really well
is stayed true to who I am and so people
who watch the show watch all my stuff
they know who I am they know what it is
they know that I'm going to say [__]
stupid [__] [__] up things or whatever
but it's all in form of Comedy so I have
that trust with people and I kind of put
that trust in everything else that I
that's the most important that really is
the most important because in what we do
uh you know now since moving on from
dorm taming we we started comedy trap
house which is our podcast Channel and
everything and I always knew that like
podcasting would be CU one thing from
dorm
tment uh that it built a large fan base
but people knew us as a group it's like
knowing wuang you might not know
everybody at first until you get to know
each other you know there was six of us
in a group
and so I felt like podcasting gave
opportunity for for people to know each
one of us you know I'm saying and really
get you know to to I hate to say buy
into but just just get to know us better
you know and if you if you know us if
you get to know us I'm sure the people
that are like us will buy into and
support what we do yeah and I think any
artist any person that's creating create
you know you have to have a you have to
develop a fan page where they know you
because I am a man just like you that
wants to say whatever the [__] I want to
say you know what I'm saying at any
point I want to talk about listen
whether we're talking about Jesus Allah
Buddha whatever they're going to get
these jokes too yeah it's the truth
you're gonna get these
jokes but I I I just feel like once you
have a audience that knows who you are
they know your characteristics they
don't know they know that you're not
coming from a place of malice or or
anything that they'll support you for
the Long Haul yeah 100 you know what I'm
saying it's it's it's not and and and if
you could find that rather than going to
these you know the studios or whatever
begging for help and having to suck you
know who you think a director is dick in
a meeting or whatever you know that is
the the route I think most people would
cherish in the long term yeah and you
know people are finding this out too
it's
like acting is such a weird thing right
I I'll talk to certain people and one of
the things that I get disappointed and
if you fall into this category you're a
piece of [__] cuz I I always hear he
people say very specific phrases they'll
say stuff like this and it sounds really
nice at first they they get into this
mind state where when they're the person
outside looking in they always judge the
people on the inside they go these
actors are a piece of [__] well guess
what when they're allowed into that
group they become that person absolutely
you're not mad at them for being pieces
of [__] you're mad that you're not a
part of that group where you get to
treat everybody else like a piece of
[__] y y and I was like that's the big
difference and I've seen that so many
times over and over
I'll give you another example I was at
this other mixer event and there was a
friend of mine who we did a lot of work
together and when I knew her at the time
this girl was on [__] welfare she
couldn't even pay her bills but she blew
up right I see her everything's cool
whatever she goes David how have you
been like like I've been meaning to
contact you blah blah blah blah let's do
lunch first of all this [__] has never
said let's do lunch to me ever I'm like
where' you get this [__] phrase from
and I looked at her I was like hey don't
don't [__] talk to me like I'm brand
new or some [__] like that I was like if
you wanted to hit me up you have my
[__] phone number hit me up right
don't do this little [__] let's do
lunch conversation [__] right and I
think also for her she forgot it's like
I'm not a part of your group I'll never
be a part of this group like you got to
talk to me how we used to talk to each
other after where she apologized she
goes yeah I don't know [__] I don't
know why I said that [__] I'm just so in
here that this is how everybody talks I
got caught up I was like yeah don't do
that [__] to me you know what I mean
like Hollywood is the real zombie
apocalypse because if you really think
about the way they go about just copying
their their their lingo and their the
way they all just melt into this pot
it's like they're and they're trying to
eat your soul too so I mean I just feel
like every industry you go into you're
going to have your annoying ass people
in and and and you're going to have the
games they play you're going to have uh
you know you're going to you're going to
have to somewhat either meld into how
they do because that's what they do you
know what I'm saying you're in their
industry the worst part about it too is
like now we're seeing this i' I've seen
it a couple of times too where I i' I've
been pretty vocal about it there are
writers now who are so untalented and
shitty that they they now scour the
internet podcast and they steal people's
life stories and they put into their
scripts like you're going to start
seeing it a lot like all the stuff that
we're putting out here it's all of our
personal lives and jokes and stories
that they don't [__] have they're
going into these podcasts and they're
like oh this is a good story this is a
good story and they're stealing it
you're not getting any credit for it and
you won't even know cuz they're going to
make the one of the Apes from Planet of
Apes have that story 100% you see it
like Theo Von he was a comedian he
started off hard play that's the next
planet of AP dude like the show Dave on
FX whoever the [__] was a writer they
stole a theovon joke and they put it
directly in the [__] script and then
theovon called it out he's like the [__]
is this [__] this is my [__] was it was
it through dialogue or was it like
visually played visually and dialogue so
he was making a joke I think it was
either on the Rogan podcast or his
podcast it's something about wooden
shirts okay about this you know cuz like
f Von always talks about these stupid
stupid hypotheticals from his like honky
talk town and they took that joke and
they put it into a script and it's like
who else thinks of some [__] like this
besides theovon damn and so like writers
are doing that so sometimes when these
writers like they're on strike and look
I'm I'm with you guys but there's a fat
chunk of you that are the most
talentless [__] I've ever met in my
life God and so they they steal all
these stories and now they're doing the
strike mad at other you know for AI and
other people like taking credit for
their stuff you already stole your
stories from other people so what the
[__] are you talking about damn David
just blew my mind with like every
podcaster out there if you're doing
online content be very wary where you
don't tell your stories and talk your
[__] but just be watch what goes online
and watch what goes on Netflix and TV
you'll see all your stories there and
it's that is crazy you'll see it I it's
already happening so I mean so even the
idea of the strike is like y'all are
stealing it's not all writers right I'm
saying there is that portion that I've
seen so many times and it pisses me off
and I've heard other tell me this stuff
too I'll bring it up I was like hey what
about this joke on this show right I was
like this sounds a little familiar to
something that I heard here and they're
like you know they kind of just I'm like
yeah exactly damn you know and and who's
to tell that AI chat GPT and all these
things aren't taking from that too other
creators YouTube uh uh podcast stories
and stuff once you know and implementing
it into because it takes from everywhere
else so yeah and this is the other
problem too what Tik Tok did something
very very good in the sense of they
found something out most people
especially young people they actually
don't care about being a creative they
don't care about credit they actually
don't care about any of that stuff they
just want people to know who they are
right Tik Tok in the first year became I
think you could probably look this up I
think they became a billion dollar
company in their first year that they
launched or something very close to that
right and they paid creators out zero
and guess what no creators complained
that's crazy none of them complained
yeah you know why cuz they don't care
about the money they care about social
currency they only want people to
recognize who they are yeah so in our
stuff was like Hey we're creating this
stuff but we need to make our paycheck
right I was at a Tik Tok event and I've
said this on this podcast before I met a
bunch of Tik tokers and not all of them
there's like the one% that does really
[__] well that's because they sell
products they do all they have a whole
management team but for the Tik Tok
creators who don't do that that don't
know how to do this stuff they have
millions of views right broke as [__] I
was like how [__] did you make this
company x amount of money and you're not
asking for anything back right but once
again they don't think like that they go
oh I went to likea on a free trip I was
like so they gave you a coach ticket
that cost a $1,000 godam to AA in this
shitty little [__] hotel and then you
thought that was payment you could have
done that and got a paycheck you never
asked so it's like Tik Tok found out
that most kids do not care about this
stuff they could just use them and then
toss them aside and they won't won't
even complain right they're just and
they're getting them I think they're
getting them so young that they're
making it where it's it's it's that's
not even a part of the culture to make
money off of it I'm saying like they're
just used to like oh I just want to be
famous right people Flex super hard on
the gram and you meet them in person I'm
like damn you broke his foot yeah dog
one of the saddest things I always see
is like an only fans girl that nobody
watches their [__] oh my god [__] you
sold your [__] for penties oh my god
did you see the video of old girl uh who
is it one former NBA player uh he he
found out his wife or or girl was doing
started doing only fans what and she
filmed him while he was the first time
he finds out so he's AR he's getting
upset and she's filming the whole sh he
got mad that he found out I have a only
fans and d d d she comes out later and
says well he knew what I did beforehand
and I guess she did maybe some stuff in
the past and this is like a I don't know
she look like she's 50 years old or
something yeah damn I mean they're black
so it looks so you know what I mean but
but it's just
like this this only fans Tik Tock all
these things are somehow gotten a grasp
on American culture by the nuts and it's
like I don't I don't know it it's it's
making the world weird and they're
having a false sense of reality where it
is they just want the attention it's not
even that much about for only fans it's
it's money but it's also attention you
know I'm saying sometimes like when I go
into like these if I've go into like
only fans and I see like a girl like you
could tell she doesn't really have it
all together a few follow and she goes
Check out my only fans and I click on
that [__] it says like three subscribers
I just want to subscribe to her just to
be like get your [__] together and then
just subscribe out P $10 get your [__]
together that is hilarious this isn't
worth it you know what I'm saying like
this is only worth it but they don't
want that man there was another video of
a guy going up to a prostitute probably
on Figaroa or something like this and
and he he says uh hey um how much and
she's like whatever whatever he's like
I'll give you he probably said double of
that just to wash my car and she said no
I'm not doing that and walked off get
the F she said no she wants to be out
here hooking that's a old ass way of
saying God damn she trying to be hooking
sheing to goddamn streets but she was
out there she literally said no to
washing this man car for possibly $200
probably take you
that's [__] wild she was like no like
it was disrespectful to say hey wash my
car for but you trying to get your dick
sucked or not like no I'll give you 200
bucks if you wash my car no um excuse
you I said this pussy's 1
15 what the [__] but dude I'm telling
you man like it's it's such a weird
space and Island Boys I text you about
that [__] bro I was I I almost threw up
in my mouth like this is what it's
becoming those boys are so [__] funny
to me because I've never seen somebody
make a defense for the videos that had
nothing to do with what people were
freaked out about they were like hey
it's cool cuz I'm gay and we're like
he's your brother the [__] man I didn't
even know they tried to defend it no
that was the defense I was like the gay
part's not the problem you're [__]
your brother like what are you talking
about he's like he's like bro I got this
we gay and then everybody was just
silent like that was never the problem
they're over here like putting like
cucumbers in their pants and they're
sucking the Cucumber off of the other
brother it's it's gotten to that point
yo this [__] is I'm not saying I
subscribed to them all right people have
been
sending I'm just saying like like that
that just shows you like the 80s the 80s
movies that predicted this future I
think is true yeah we're in the 80s
movies timeline RoboCop with that future
we're in Robocop bro black Black Mirror
yeah the newest season doesn't even
affect me because we're living it now
right right it's just regular I'm like
what I'm I'm watching the news oh it's
Black
Mirror what the [__] do nothing
different it's such a weird space and
you know let me ask you this would you
would you date a girl if she had an only
fans [__] no [__] no I don't want any I
think all I think there is a a uh
demonic
spirit in some of these hoes where's the
[__] Church organ at right now come
on I I I
really but is something like I I would
not suggest anybody data only fans model
I don't suggest anybody like and and the
sad thing is it the future seems to hold
nothing but
that you know
everybody's fellas your daughters are
going to be on only fans let's just keep
it real like it's just going to happen
they're going to end up on only fans if
my daugh if I have a daughter and she
wants again I pray that she looks just
like me oh I [__] pray so you take a
picture yourself and be like hey fellas
this is what you want to see you want to
see this [__] you want to see this [__]
right now so she has zero fans and she
just shelling out [__] for [__]
nothing genius brain listeners this
podcast is brought to you by
nordvpn if you haven't been using a VPN
while you're surfing online everybody
can see your stuff if you're worried
about Security in the real world the
digital world is just as dangerous
because people can grab your information
know what you're watching and guess what
even if you're surfing casually you
should always use a VPN because why not
why why why show everybody your goodies
huh would you do that in real life you
shouldn't do it online and guess what we
spend a lot of time online now cyber
security threats are a real thing it's
not stuff that you just see on TV or
whatever and then you're like oh it's
not going to happen to me it's happening
to you right now so make sure that you
get a VPN and do what nordvpn they are
trusted so exclusive grab the nordvpn
deal go to nordvpn.com / geniusbrain and
get extra subscription time try it
risk-free now with a 30-day money back
guarantee thanks to nordvpn for
sponsoring our show [__] do you see
those videos I forgot some dudes with a
podcast but they always have like only
fans girls debate yeah the fresh inits
and stuff like that yeah or something
like that and they're always called
whatever yeah yeah yeah whatever oh yeah
yeah yeah okay yes
see he subscribed that's why he like I'm
a fan oh man hilarious yeah but they
always debate these other people and you
know obviously they're getting people
who can't really defend themselves but
every time the the only argument that
they have is like well I'm out here
making money it's like okay that's it
this is your only basis for you to show
value in your life it's just not for me
like I obviously grew up different you
know I just can't agree with that no and
it's like you know also too you know
some people like well why do you care
about what they do it's like because
they are a representation of the future
right they're a younger generation they
represent the future that's that's why I
care it it's just random to say that
it's weird to say that to like to hear
why why should you care why why do you
like do I shouldn't care about Society I
shouldn't care about like what happens
for our kids future for the future of
other people like where this whole thing
goes like I shouldn't care I just don't
like too it's like if your whole
branding and idea is I'm going to get
butt naked and suck dick and then the
sentence after that is that why don't
you respect my mind like cuz I'm not
masturbating to your
mind my mind is the [__] you talking
about you read it the source to me and
I'm be like yeah right right right I
mean it's just weird you could be
jacking off to to only fans girls while
watching YouTube while they're talking
to these only fans girls and then sexy
red is talking about booty hole Brown it
just feels like a weird weird time to be
cuz it goes against everything I grew up
with right yes yes yes yes yes yes like
as as uh Millennials I guess we're the
last of this we're like this cross
generation right like this of of of kids
that knew pre- internet and now we're
here with the internet but I you know I
was grow up to to treat women
differently to the that they're not to
be harmed they're to be you know uh oh
dud be swinging on girls now oh my God
saw a video of blueface talking to his
girl in the car uh talking about he was
like well you start fights she was like
you start fights with me he was like I
don't give a [__] you start you say
something to me I'll beat the [__] out
of you I'm like and then everybody just
like that's what it is yeah oh good
content they go equal rights equal lefts
is what they it's like Jesus Christ dude
what the [__] is going this why we can't
do skits anymore like the world is fun
this is a sketch all of this is a sketch
you got Island Boy The Brothers making
out for Content you know you got [__]
you know this is ridiculous man yeah
like y old woman coming out saying I'm
on only fans the world what are you
doing the world went to [__] when
[__] Rachel doal opened up an only
fans yes oh my God y hey I'm not going
to lie I [__] reddited that fit now
she got some nice titties my question is
is her booty hole Brown that's what I
want to know is it brown or is it pink
need know when I saw that I was like
what the [__] is going on right now why
got transracial booty hole that's what
that's what I believe trans is she is
she on her black or is she a white you
don't know which is she in the ebony
category or the you know she [__]
fooled us though she fooled us like the
world when I saw like if I look at her I
actually know a girl who's half black
half white that actually looks like
Rachel doal so it it tripped me out I'm
like holy [__] there's plenty of them is
she Jewish is that what it is I don't
know I saw CU Jewish people kind of have
like those features hair curly hair they
can have froze I don't think she has
naturally curly hair cuz I saw a photo
of her when she was younger she was
blonde okay she's blonde with straight
hair she looked like she turns butter
like that she like from The Source like
she came from a waterfall like she's
like that type of white eight and a half
B exactly white okay yeah but when she
started open up the only D I feel bad
for her kids cuz her kids were getting
bullied in school because of that [__]
kids what time are we at right now 45
minutes okay awesome um so I wanted to
talk about this but we got it it's
[__] sidetracked but I'm just going
to throw it in just because it's great
for
titles so Chandler Bing Chandler
Chandler Bing for friends yes what is
his actual name I know I hope when I
hope when major news outlets come out
they didn't just call him
Chandler mat Perry Matthew Perry there
you go Matthew Perry passes away yes you
know I feel like if you guys got to see
who uh if you guys ever watched Friends
throughout like the 10 seasons right you
saw Matthew Perry kind of go up and down
in weight the way that he looks what a
lot of people didn't know on the outside
especially because you know we were so
young when it came out he was actually
going through a lot of drug addictions
Lot Like Cocaine everything that you
name it and then when he while the show
was going on while the show was going on
that's the I mean I know this has
nothing to do with it but I'm actually
pretty amazed because I believe it was
like the third or fourth season when he
was super skinny that's when he was
abusing drugs like crazy okay but his
acting was still on point there is a
different caliber level of acting when
you're a drug addict and you still show
up and [__] kill it damn dog but did
it enhance his acting is that what it
did you maybe I don't know because if
enhance his acting which one of y'all
got some I know when I when I when I
heard about this [__] they found out
what he was dead in his hot tub yeah
after playing pickle ball pickle ball
yeah he playing pickle ball have you
heard of pickle ball I've heard of it
but I don't know how it would do blackf
play pickle ball no I don't all
right yeah is that incorporate a smaller
ball we like big balls
it like football balls basketball actual
nuts actual nuts it it blew up in the
last like five or six years but it's
like pingpong and uh tennis mixed
together okay okay right so it blew up
recently everybody's playing pickle ball
you go into like South Pasadena Sherman
Oaks you see a tennis court they're
converting it into pickle ball courts
okay so it's like yeah so it's that big
right now huge industry but uh what are
the people like that are in there they
kind of old and white old and white okay
typically old and white I'm going to go
out and play some pickle ball old and
white or young Asian there's there's no
in between okay all right all but he was
he has a pickle ball coach he was
playing I didn't know there was pickle
ball coaches in the first place but he
was doing that in his hot tub and then
his assistant found him dead in the hot
tub and you told me somebody took a
photo of him and released it yeah I saw
I saw it online they had a picture of
him in the hot tub with I mean I I hope
he wasn't dead in the picture I don't
think he was just chilling I hope he was
just chilling but it somebody said it
was before he passed so that's [__]
crazy man knows I don't know yeah he was
going through a whole bunch of [__] and
like I always wondered too there's like
this weird thing where people don't
there's a fat group of people who hate
friends they think friends is like one
of the worst sitcoms of all time I've
never really I I've watched a couple
episodes but I I've never judged I just
knew it as an American staple and then I
know the song obviously but I wasn't
into the show as much was he like who
was the Jennifer Anderson was obviously
like the stand out right the show had
such a good ensemble cast everybody
played an important part okay it was it
was hard to say who you liked more
because everybody was so [__]
different and this is like during the
Golden Age of sitcoms where sitcom
actors were the [__] they were so good
at what they [__] did right and so
friends was probably known the most for
their cast chemistry they had some of
the best cast chemistry you could have
ever seen on on a long-going sitcom and
they were also obviously in the last
season I think everybody paid a mill an
episode and this was back in the day you
could have imagine how much money they
all made so they're pretty much set for
life right um for him like this he was
he kind of played the the goofy quirky
guy that had a lot of commitment issues
that's right yeah and everybody loved
his weird character he eventually got
together with uh Ross Geller his sister
and that was like a whole fun little
story arc that they did the writing was
really good and the jokes were really on
point a lot of people for some reason
like the sect of people I think it's
just counterculture like counterculture
they just don't want to like friends
they think that is [__] terrible and
listen for me too it wasn't really up my
alley in humor but as I watched it the
cast chemistry was so [__] funny it
made me laugh cuz one of my my what's
your favorite sitcom of all
time that's hard to say man I mean you
got
your favorite sitcom I mean you got
your fresh princes you have your
Seinfeld you have SE Seinfeld's up there
for me too Fresh Prince is up there for
me um what's another good
one Martin Martin of course Cosby
Show like black sitcoms in the '90s well
I feel like all white sitcoms were were
great '90s and that early 2000s was
amazing of Queens Everybody Loves
Raymond yes all all these like stand up
Comics were getting their own shows yeah
man that was such a good time to watch
TV Saved by the Bell even the kids yeah
yeah hisid shows that were sitcoms were
amazing you know what I mean my favorite
of all time sadly enough was the co is
The Cosby Show really I've watched The
Cosby Show from first season all the way
till end probably over like 40 or 50
times what's the first scene that comes
in your mind when you think of cos the
very first episode of The Cosby Show
where Theo was sitting in his bedroom
okay and then he told oh I know what you
with the bat the Cosby he goes why can't
you just love me for who I am he's like
that's the stupidest thing I've ever
heard in my life you know it was like a
shocking thing for sitcom cuz you never
saw the sitcom dad do that to the kid
and so Bill Cosby you know for what it's
worth let me tell you something I love
Bill Cosby so much when all these
allegations came out I was like this is
not real when allegation 78 came out I
was like maybe maybe when 356 came out I
was like maybe he did this all right
just maybe but I loved Bill Cosby I had
a I had a a wall of comedians that I
respected right it was Bill Cosby there
was Dave Chappelle and then there was
Eddie Murphy and I had three posters
side by side that [__] I was all right
cos people were walk into the room
they're like yo what the [__] I'm like
it hasn't been proven yet I just hear
music We Fall
Down we get up do so I had to take that
[__] down and then Bill Cosby for me was
just
like he was like the ultimate sitcom
family right you had um Felicia Rashad
CLA hux she never played the typical
housewife that was just cleaning around
the house law she was a lawyer she was a
partner at a [__] Law Firm she
matched do you believe in that dynamic
in real life could that work pro I mean
I have uh a friend lawyer and a doctor
well two two lawyers one's uh in the
military and the other one works at a
law firm and they're both like
powerhouses and it works okay you know
what I'm saying so like they have kids
two kids okay nice yeah and so like
watching them do it and like like seeing
that whole dynamic it kind of like also
molded what the type of partner that I
wanted gr up too cuz she wasn't
subservient she wasn't just Naggy for no
reason like he was more of the one that
was all over the place and she was the
rock of the family so you kind of got to
see this really dope Dynamic that I
didn't get to see in a lot of sitcoms
they were funny and also too they
flirted they were still dating they had
like that sexual tension too which was
dope you know Cliff was banging that
back know he was you know he was dude
Lisa Bonet I had a huge crush on Lisa B
oh my God who didn't man she was so bad
I thought all of them were pretty Dude
sandre too the the actress that played
Sandra I thought she was super pretty
too in a different type of oh yeah yeah
I I even thought as Aid not weird [__]
but Raven when she grew up I was like oh
she's going to be pretty when she grows
up she did a little different thing as
she
but she got them D's on her though oh
she definitely got them D's but them D's
are for them uh them ladies you know
what the saddest thing is like the only
the biggest thing I remember of her
aside from The Cosby Show is Orlando
Bloom talking about him sucking on her
titties oh my God that [__] is so funny
this one said oh I had them things I was
doing
that that [__] was hilarious oh my God
Orlando Brown lost his [__] mind but
it was so entertaining U look you know
what's crazy that boy can rap he can rap
He I've heard songs where he's rapping
I'm like okay I was actually shocked I
actually didn't know he's actually so
talented he just lost his mind it's so
funny like it feels like all the the
people we're talking about are [__] up
in some ways now you know Orlando Bill K
be I know but they all had like talent
and they were great and it's like do you
appreciate appreciate them not the same
but obviously like not as the person but
do you appreciate their work still do
you separate art from artist Artistry I
mean I can't look at Cosby the same way
but I could still watch all the Cosby
Show because of what it did for me as a
kid growing up right you know what I'm
saying like it molded half my comedy yes
like half my jokes is based off of The
Cosby Show that's my biggest influence
so there's no way that I could erase
that right it's just it's just hard to
let me tell you something I just got
married I had to resist the urge to play
R Kelly oh my God I resist I didn't I
didn't do it but I wanted re I was
playing AR on the way
here I wanted ignition to play so bad oh
my God because it's you have you have to
understand how many bangers he but it's
too weird now right it's just it's a
little weird like some I'll have it on
and I you know I get the feelings of
like oh man she's a banger I'm like yeah
this [__] be raping though you
know and it's really hard I think my my
home cam say says uh well too he says
the the content reflects the what he did
it's too close to what he's done yeah
it's like all sexual music yeah it's
very sexualizing it's like are you
talking about a little girl in this song
or that song yeah I don't know yeah I I
and at least with The Cosby Show he's
playing Heathcliff hustable right he's
not Bill Cosby so I'm looking at him as
a sitcom character R Kelly is just a
singer and he's that person so it's
always a little [__] weird yeah I
mean with Michael Jackson nothing was
proven nothing so I could I could stay
in purgatory for the rest of my life we
we going to stay there and I already
told you he talked about them titties
yes talked about them titties that that
was evidence hey what person who likes
little children talks about big old
gazungas you know Michi ladas dude man
CH that's right this guy if he looks at
a full grown adult looks at the titties
and he goes yeah yeah done yeah we we we
can be in the same room they should have
put that [__] in the court case that
[__] would have been closed like that oh
my God yeah yeah yeah get him out of
here he's a free
man free man you just see like your
honor right here right get him out he's
done he's he's a free man look at him
fishies fishies well guys that wraps up
this episode of the Gus braid podcast uh
you could catch well give give them all
your socials oh man please uh number one
catch me at comedy Trap House on YouTube
Instagram that is our podcast show um
that we do and we have different game
shows different things on there that we
drop so join me there I have a show on
there called Mayhem hour every Friday at
7 it's a live show if you guys want
tojoy we talk about all the craziness
conspiracies all the wild [__] that's
going on in the world and we try to
laugh before the apocalypse so uh that's
that's pretty much it you can follow me
at Emanuel Richard on Instagram perfect
uh genius PR every Sundays at 12:00 pm
uh secret society the first launch of
the year is out uh genius brain and
secret society will do be doing a collab
piece in the next month and then after
that I got a couple of separate items
that I'll be selling for just genius
bring Al loone because a lot of people
are asking for just regular merchandise
for the podcast in December that's going
to happen so check out check or wait for
that and we'll see you all next time
peace genius brain listeners this
podcast is sponsored and brought to you
by Harry's my friends if you're looking
for a quality razor that doesn't break
the bank then you're in it to win it
with Harry's I've been using the
products for quite a while now I use to
shave my face my armpits my balls my
chest everything you name it I don't
have a single hair on my body I am like
a sexy
dolphin that's that is a dolphin and
that is me when I use Harry's Razors the
starter set is a $13 value for just $3
at harry's.com genius it includes a five
blade German engineer razor weighted
handle foaming shave gel and a travel
cover and listen scheduled delivery for
refills as low as $2 for half of what
you pay for other blades the best get
your best shave ever with Harry's razor
and skincare product get a $13 starter
set for just $3 at harris.com genius
that's harris.com genius for a $3
starter set today